[Applaus]
hallo wunderbar [Applaus]
wissen sie auch nicht mehr was sie essen
sollen ist doch überall Chemie drin oder
Pestizide in der Paprika Dioxin im Ei
Antibiotika ein Hähnchen ich finde man
muss das mittlerweile einfach positiv sehen
ich habe noch nicht am Hähnchengrill gestanden
habe zur Verkäuferin gesagt das ist aber teuer
das Hähnchen haben sie nur eins von ratiopharm
euch das billiger gekriegt so wunderbar oder ja
man muss sich das einfach richtig schön machen
im Leben und ähm ist man weiß man aber heute
gar nicht mehr wie man seine Kinder gesund
ernähren soll oder darf ich mal fragen wer von
ihnen hat Kinder dass Mama auf wer hat keine
der Rest ist schwanger ja klar von
denen keine Kinder haben wir welche
aber nicht mit dem Partner mit dem
sie gerade zusammen sind [Applaus]
oder erzähle ich von mir ich habe
mittlerweile welche und ich muss sagen
die ernähren sich momentan ausschließlich
von Dominosteinen und marzipanbroten
gut die Essen das jetzt auch nicht so lange
seit August [Musik] das gut dass man sich in
Deutschland immer fünf Monate vorher schon
auch so ein Fest einstimmen kann und damit
wir da turnusmäßig nicht aus dem Tritt kommen
lese ich jetzt eine Geschichte zum Thema Ostern
ich ziehe das so durch sondern
Block eines einjährigen Kindes
das Massiv früh gefördert worden ist
das noch nicht sprechen kann und sich
deshalb per Internet ausdrücken muss
und wie dieses Kind das erste Osterfest
mit seinen Eltern erlebt das lese ich jetzt
Ostern Mama weckt mich und sag der Osterhase
war da war denke ich und dreh mich noch mal um
Mama wird ungeduldig und sagte
ich soll ihr beim Eier suchen
helfen Mama verlegt alles finde das um
8 Uhr morgens kein Mensch Eier braucht
und baue aus Lego ein betreutes
Wohnprojekt für Alzheimer Kranke
Mama findet das nicht witzig
und besteht auf Eiersuche
ich helfe gerne Robbe in die Küche und ziehe
an der Kühlschranktür 10 Eier in Reih und Glied
Mama schüttelt den Kopf und trägt
mich schnurstracks Richtung Garten
gucke im Flur in die Einkaufstasche von
gestern tatsächlich alle 50 Eier weg
Mama wirkt verzweifelt und sagt ich solle
nun endlich die Eier im Garten suchen
mir schwant Böses hatte mir neulich einen Hund
gewünscht Hund nicht Huhn klingt ähnlich ein Huhn
hat aber kein Fell und holt kein Stöckchen Mama
hört schlechter als die wie wonder sehen kann
wenn ich Keks sage kriege ich zum Beispiel immer
Vollkornbrot mit Dinkel Tofu erzählte [Applaus]
also die Terrassentür öffnet atme
ich auf kein Huhn ist in Sicht
nur meine komplett versammelte Verwandtschaft
die sich hinter der Regentonne versteckt
ich drehe ab Richtung Lego heim doch Mama schnappt
mich hebt mich hoch und zeigt auf die fossie
und bin ich ehrlich überrascht der
gelbe Strauch hängt voll mit bunten
Eiern wieder was gelernt die Hühner kacken
Pastell und der Osterhase kann fliegen
Papa trägt mich zu einer kokosformation und sagt
ja Cookie mal da ja Cookie
mal was da ist ui ui ui ui
i tatsächlich
vier bunte Eier Strahlen aus dem Strauß
heraus wie kontaminierte Teletubbies
den genauso aus wie die die
Mama gestern gekocht hat
müssen aber andere sein denn
Mama erkennt sie nicht wieder
gucke mich um überall Eier der
Hase hat sie nicht mehr alle
klaut im Huni Früchte der Zeugung und versteckt
über fremden Leuten Armes Häschen bist du krank
sicher schwere Kindheit gehabt oder kein
Häschen zum rammeln gefunden [Applaus]
gegen Mittag haben meine Eltern endlich auch
die Nase voll alle Eier werden eingesammelt
und die Party ist vorbei Oma erzählt noch
was von einem Herrn Jesus der heute aufsteht
mache ich jeden Tag [Applaus] [Gelächter]
war schon witzig übrigens davon gibt es noch
mehr wenn Sie das hier abonnieren also drücken